Ennis pie who considers himself a
conservative Muslim once backed the
Turkish president but these days he's
taking a firm stance in the drive to
defeat the referendum that would grant
retro type heir to one more power in his
outreach to other devout Muslims in
Istanbul he echoes the warnings of other
activists that a yes vote will pave the
way to autocracy perspective what we're
witnessing in the country today is a big
step backwards our democracy has been
weakened and the government is
distancing itself further from Islamic
values that's why we've taken to the
street pays religious and no campaign
doesn't get much positive response in
this conservative district but erawan
supporters are keen to talk about the
presidential system the Turkish leader
wants to introduce one passerby asked if
there isn't a similar system in the
United States known says pie in America
the government lawmakers and judiciary
aren't rolled into one
further right-wing resistance to air
Dewan comes from merrill oksana a former
interior minister whose nationalist MHP
party is backing Erin's proposal but she
herself is against it her motives beyond
defeating the referendum aren't clear
but she enjoys a large following that's
why she's now banned for making
appearances in many areas her gatherings
are often met with violent opposition
and a spice platform for law and justice
is out campaigning they use a megaphone
atop their van to spread their messages
such as dictatorship and corruption our
sins they're undeterred by attacks from
the government alleging their
collaboration with secular Turks
and Kurdish groups I think it's already
a victory for us that so many different
social groups have come together to
block this development the fact that
even conservative circles express doubts
about the planned presidential system is
a bigger problem for president Allen
than the criticism from the left
officially the government continues to
be confident but the polls speak of a
head-to-head race between opponents and
advocates of the constitutional reforms
the questions many people here ask is
whether an Iran would really give up his
plans for a presidential system if he
were to be narrowly defeated in the vote
on Sunday